ladies and gentlemen happy 4th of july
welcome to the tim dillon show it is
summer i am here in my final form
sitting next to the luckiest person in
show business
benjamin
avery
my best fourth of july memory was when
an uncle of mine we had a great fourth
of july party at uh uh my uncle's house
every single year and one of his
brothers
uh was offended because i think somebody
called his wife a name i think they said
she's a jew
now this is what happened it's an irish
uh family of drunks and he tried he was
gonna drive home drunk but what they did
was they like took the air out of his
tires they went out they did a whole
thing and
they were like hitting his car his tire
like it was crazy and me and a friend
just kind of watched this
from behind a bush and we watched my
family take the air out of this guy's
tire so he literally could not
drive home because there was a big
fight
about his wife
they're since uh divorced
fun fourth of july memory because it's
independence day it's freedom it's uh
it's important that people go out there
they put some meat on the grill and they
they just uh you know again take stock
of where they are and what they have
and uh it's the summer is in full swing
and people are happy out there and
you know i mean it's it's we're back
we're back baby america is back and
nothing's gonna keep us down not the
crime or the gas prices the unemployment
the lack of money uh the family
structure that's rapidly dissolving
uh you know the rise of militias
nothing will
keep us down i mean we're back in
business
in a serious way isn't that the way you
feel oh yeah we're back it's gonna be a
great summer what's going on out there
that's making it great
well there's actually things that are
not making it great well wait what what
i was just sort of agreeing with you but
actually i don't really have any
information to support that claim uh a
lot of fourth of july is being canceled
uh due to uh labor shortages why wait a
minute
hold the phone
how can you cancel
the fourth
of july
what would that even look like
well it would so some cities like in
arizona are replacing it with
they're replacing it with since their
supply chain issues they can't get any
they can't get any fireworks right in
the whole state so what they're going to
do is a pyrotechnic show
okay instead as a replacement
okay
so some cities are new you know they
don't want to not do anything on the
fourth they're still going to have a
show with big flames shooting out of
pipes i guess
well they can't get fireworks yeah it's
supply chain issues they're unable to
secure
fireworks for a firework show so they're
gonna do what are they gonna do like a
uh a drag show
they should that'll make everyone nice
and happy
it'll piss every you know i would do a
drag brunch the other day a pride brunch
you know i'm a i was i've always been a
fan of drag queens
mostly when they were like politically
incorrect very acerbic
nasty funny
um
but now it's a lot you know you're
eating uh breakfast there and you have
the drag queens like yeah it's bad like
in your
face and you're just trying to eat
french toast
and it's just gotten very aggressive you
know what i mean there's like a boot in
your face and they're like lick the bird
you know and you're like okay you're
like i'm
this is enjoyable and i'm there with a
guy that we just [ __ ] it's not i'm not
like coming from a christian coalition
meeting i'm sitting there with another
[ __ ] and it's still
a lot
you know
the drag brunch where they're like ah
it's like a whole
thing and then you know it's
some of it is camp and fun and some of
it is you know i wish you had real
talent
because some of the drag queens are like
wouldn't it be funny if i was a singer
or a dancer yeah it would also be
entertaining do that
um now
so now these places in uh where where
are these they're gonna they're not
letting people go to the fourth of
they're not letting people go to the
fourth of july yeah yeah most of arizona
seems to be kind of hosed this year
arizona is a real dump i mean it's a
real it's just a bunch of lot lizards
living in the dirt
and they deserve what they get oh yeah
but it's shocking to me that that's a
state that i feel like would spend 11
months out of the year securing
fireworks like what the [ __ ] else are
they doing playing golf
by the way i look like the mayor
of the governor of arizona right now
like this outfit i look like the mayor
the governor
the poet laureate of arizona
um but
i'll tell you this right now are there
are there any fun
like uh substitutions for the fireworks
what are they gonna do so like i'm
reading here in lieu of fireworks and
this is tempe tempe in lieu of fireworks
the city will host red white and flume
red white and flume f-l-o-o what's that
it's a fire show scheduled to begin at 8
30. there will be 12 floating
flower-shaped flumes on tempe town link
and they shoot flames up to 30 feet in
the air and it's a five-minute
pyrotechnic show people are not gonna
like this
this is gonna bomb
flower-shaped flumes shooting flames
they are not gonna like this they want
their fireworks why don't they just show
up with a bunch of ar-15s
and shoot at the sky
so at least they have something that's
audible they can hear
they are not going to like this flume
oh man they are not going to like this
flume
these people in tempe arizona want one
thing
loud
gun-like
fireworks to enjoy for the fourth of
july
they want loud
bang
you know i don't love fireworks i've
said before they're kind of pedestrian
but
you know for the fourth of july you do
it you do it once a year and you enjoy
it and you move on but the idea that
they're gonna replace it with this uh
flume
is not going to what are there any other
cities uh the city of chandler uh
they're gonna again in arizona yeah yeah
the hell's going on i don't know they
well this guy what is chandler doing
they don't have any [ __ ] money
what the hell is the fireworks show
being replaced with in chandler arizona
uh well so there's a pyro planning
specialist named kenden victor oh god
and um he said it's an industry-wide
nationwide issue actually oh
and uh so he's in charge of all the
pyrotechnics
what's his name uh
kendon victor
kendon
victor
he's a pyrotechnics expert
yes okay so he's going to be overseeing
the um the replacement shows here but
he's saying we're using the wrong terms
here it's not a firework shortage uh
it's just an issue with supply chain so
i know that whatever from china is what
do you say yeah okay well i know but
what's what's the difference yeah that's
just what he's just trying to correct
people on that but
all of uh arizona is kind of hosed here
uh with it so but i think ken and victor
is is feeling good uh with the two-star
news here that uh he's gonna kind of
come through and
power through he said we continue to
receive phone calls from other states
other cities requesting to see if we
could provide for their fourth of july
but we provide exclusively for the state
of arizona so he's going to try to
figure it out for the state
well i i hope because this is such a big
national uh celebration that i hope that
it is not dampened by the uh no
fireworks i hope people can still get
hurt
i hope people can still go out and get
really intoxicated and look at bright
colors in the sky and it hopefully will
alleviate some of the pain because we've
had some pain i forgot to include that
also the pyrotechnics show it's
choreographed to patriotic and pop music
it says on the city's event listing
reads i hope it's so gay
that everyone is so uncomfortable with
it i hope it's so over the top like lady
gaga gay
i hope that like it's just all gay
colors
and
it's so uncomfortable for the residents
of tempe that there's like a riot
i hope they start taking their guns out
i i believe by the way no matter what
happens they're going to start shooting
the flames with the guns because they're
going to be so upset
by this because all they want
is a
old-school firework show like they grew
up with
you know
and they're it's going to be replaced by
some like cirque du soleil
freak show
and the people that live by like these
man-made lakes in arizona
these tarantulas
that come out
for this event
are going to be so disappointed
by this pyrotechnics
show
and i'm um
i'm sad about it i'm truly sad about it
fourth of july is is a
it's a it's an interesting holiday
because it's something that you spend
around your family a lot of times not
always
but it's a family event where you go
and you spend it
with people in your family or community
like long island they do a thing the
gucci brothers in new york city and long
island do a fireworks spectacular
like it's a big deal you have the
burgers the hot dogs you have your flag
cake your american flag cake and you
just feel
good you feel proud of our country for
one night
and it's good you you celebrate
you know just being an american whatever
that means
the the backyard pool
the [ __ ] booze
the food the [ __ ] cable news loudly
chirping in the background
the air conditioning the consumption of
energy
the big suvs
dad getting home
mom working hard in the kitchen dad on
the grill
mom icing a cake
your brother doing fentanyl
whatever
it means to be an american
fourth of july is it it is the most
american thing i could think of can you
think of any more american holiday than
the fourth of july with the barbecue
outside the pool the fireworks no
because it's our independence
yeah
but
stylistically it just is the most
american thing you can do
it's the most american thing you can do
and i'm trying to remember if i've ever
had like epic fourth of july they've
always been fine
you know yeah fine they've always been
fine they've never been great
but they've always been something to do
where you'd go out and you go we have
something to do
tonight
and you would stand there
and it would happen
and it was never great
they were never great
whatever feelings you're supposed to
feel
i don't know i don't remember maybe when
i was younger
or even in my high school or early
college i don't remember what i did
for the fourth of july do you remember
any fourth of july i remember it stood
out in your memory one i remember being
on a boat somewhere on a lake in texas
oh oh oh because everybody goes out on
the boat yeah at night and then people
shoot off fireworks from their boats
right into the sky right and i think i
saw fireworks at disney once that was
way cooler you were at disney not on the
fourth not on the fourth okay they do
the fireworks thing every night when did
you go to disney i was 12.
disney world yeah disney the one in uh
outside wondering they had the money to
take you there in orlando well we drove
across we couldn't fly right you drove
across in the in the village you stayed
at a hotel in the on the property no no
we stay with my uncle
right
now
i just want to get to the bottom of that
and we'll get to the bottom of that
going to disney world what
i'm telling you right now everybody has
an online business i have one you have
one your mother has one my mother has
and our fathers have one our
grandparents have on our great
grandparents everybody's had an online
business forever and will forever you're
in the black mirror now baby you're in
the internet and if you want to make any
scratch any revenue any cha-ching change
you better get online and start selling
anything you got but you need to focus
on growing your business marketing
branding things like that you need to
focus on client acquisition right a
customer base developing one what you
don't need to focus on is shipping
it's so hard to focus on what really
matters in life especially if you're
running a business shipstation gives
e-commerce sellers like you more time to
do what they really love unless you
really love managing every little single
detail of order fulfillment shipstation
is an automated back office it's amazing
okay you can get back to focusing on
bigger things like developing new
products honing a marketing strategy
interacting with customers shipstation
works with all your storefronts amazon
ebay etsy and more unless you automate
the manual work that goes into shipping
you also get deeply discounted rates
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies and you can easily compare
carriers rates and delivery time so it's
easy to choose the best option for every
shipping scenario
in fact 98 of companies that use
shipstation for year continue using it
for as long as they're in business
it's time to let go of all those
shipping tasks shipstation can do it
better and faster sign up using promo
code tim dillon for a free 60-day trial
so if you're starting a business you
want 60 days off shipping
shipstation.com promo code tim dillon
and start saving time with every
shipment that's two whole months of
shipping made quick and painless and
it's free to try just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in tim
dillon ship station make ship happen for
most of us learning a second language in
high school or college wasn't exactly a
high point in our academic careers now
thanks to babel the language learning
app and by the way i've told you this
i'm embarrassed i only speak english
right
but babel is a great language learning
app that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions there's an addictively fun
and easy way to learn a new language
whether you're traveling abroad
connecting in a deeper way with family
or you just have some free time it's
also if you can speak different
languages it opens up people that you
can have sex with people that you can
have relationships with places you can
go places you can live
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
ai for their lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian or germany you're using
babel right now right i'm learning
swedish it's amazing so exciting say
something in swedish
or you're shut up there are so many ways
to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcasts games
video stories and even live classes plus
it comes with a 20 day money back
guarantee start your new language
learning journey today with babel right
now save up to 60 percent off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
babel.com
up to 60 off your subscription babble
language for life um so what else is
going on that might be
i want to find things that make people
happy god damn it it's the fourth of
july it's actually july
there might be a local beer shortage in
pennsylvania too everybody's striking
it's just shortages yeah uh i'm trying
to think of some good news i want
something that people can glom onto here
and go thank god something good's
happening it's the fourth of july can
there is there's got to be one positive
news story
did a [ __ ] walk again or something i
gotta i got a thing on a kid uh yeah has
a lemonade stand in detroit no yes this
is what we need what's going on with it
did he get shot
i hope he didn't get shot i'll throw you
right out of here no it's a sweet news
story there's a boy
in detroit
great city who has a lemonade stand yes
and the the lemonade he sells it and all
these bikers come and all these people
come what do you mean bikers like bikers
come by you know bikers oh people on
bicycles well you know those guys defend
kids and stuff and they like kill
pedophiles and stuff like that i don't
know that well no one knows what you're
talking about well bikers notoriously
they love kids
and they always defend kids isn't that a
little weird in and of itself
it is odd it's a little saucy you're
going to the lemonade stand whatever i'm
i'm glad they're defending kids but my
point is this what
we didn't have to veer off into this
weird territory with this story there's
a there's a child
selling lemonade in detroit yes and what
is happening he is raising money yes to
donate to the local animal shelter
because right now uh there's a lot of
dogs in in need of homes and with the
heat now let's just cut the end of the
story
how about this he's got a lemonade stand
and it's nice
not he's raising money
for local pit bulls who've been made to
fight each other that are now bleeding
out in a shelter
is there a way that we can turn it
around so that we could just focus on a
lovely little capitalist child
making lemonade in the hopes that one
day he will dethrone dole
and he can have the cia go down to latin
america
and prop up government so that his
company can function appropriately
i mean is there we could just tell it
without that we don't need to
right
is there anything else positive
happening something good or even if we
have to put a positive spin on something
negative uh
oh uh there's some workers at the mars
wrigley plant in pennsylvania they fell
into a vat of chocolate and this is fun
because many of them are exhausted
from the hours and hours of work that
they do for low pay
and they and they're unable to take
breaks and eat
and so they become slightly they get a
you know a head rush right they're a
little uh light on their feet right what
do you call that why am i blanking uh
when you're vision you lose your voice
they're lightheaded yeah they're
lightheaded they have low blood sugar
they're lightheaded ironically this is a
fun one
one of them falls into a pot of
chocolate but it's not like willy wonka
where that's fun he actually had to go
to the hospital
right yeah they're in the hospital they
had to be rescued there to cut a hole
bobby can you pull up the article just
pull it up wrong bobby
[Music]
these guys what were they doing sucking
each other off
[Laughter]
so these two worthless pieces of [ __ ]
are making mars bars where
uh outside hershey 15 miles outside
hershey and american chocolate tastes
like [ __ ] uh soap
now
so there it's horrible american
chocolate is disgusting everyone knows
it
what candy were they working on
uh so it's the mars wrigley plant
so i guess it's just the general
chocolate they use for all their
chocolates right in a big and why what
happened to these two idiots where they
fell in a vat of chocolate how
embarrassing so the of course the
company's not releasing it right two
people that work for an outside
contracting firm said it's not clear
they fell in the tank but emergency
responders were able to free the pair by
cutting a hole in the bottom of the tank
and and getting them out
that's that's how these people were
rescued uh it wasn't clear if they're
injured or not they're not uh telling us
that but they were taken to the hospital
to be able to and by the way if you
think that chocolate that those two dirt
bags swam around in is not finding its
way to your shelves you are wrong
you are mistaken
because that chocolate is going right
out and it's hitting the production line
those two
[ __ ] slobs
i mean how embarrassing is that
they fell into the vat of chocolate
like the joker
and they got to cut a hole in a vat of
chocolate
so that's the good news that's the good
news these are the good stories two
overworked light-headed workers fell
into a vat of chocolate before they had
to be removed via a hole that was cut
into the vat of chocolate and now and
they went to the hospital is there any
update on their condition no i tried to
find out
is there nothing else positive going on
oh uh kyle rittenhouse released a new
video game
okay
we're getting warmer america
oh say
can you see
now kyle rittenhouse if you don't know
is the young man who went to a kenosha
wisconsin
to uh
guard the things that are there
and he got in well that's his claim
right he was guarding the things
whatever needs guarding
and he got into it he shot a couple of
people
the media kind of sandbagged him it did
seem to be self-defense though it's not
a great idea to show up with an ar-50
but people will get mad at me no it is
[Applause]
but whatever i get it i can find a child
and be like hey don't go with the gun
and because that's the job of police now
with the police doing it no that doesn't
mean you do it
it means you try to get them to do their
[ __ ] jobs
um or you just get rid of them and say
these [ __ ] green haired [ __ ] [ __ ]
in portland are right
anyway
kyle rittenhouse has released a video
game now is it a shooter game it is it
is it is yeah it is kyle rittenhouse has
now released a video game where he is
you're shooting you play as kyle and
you're you're not shooting people it's
called turkey shoot and you're shooting
fake news turkeys there's a short
trailer bobby if you want to pull it up
it kind of shows again
we're trying to find oh my jesus christ
these are the fake news turkeys
supposedly these are the fake news
turkeys and kyle rittenhouse is now
shooting the fake news turkeys
that's kind of his promotion can we go
back with the british
like
can we admit this has been a mistake
like this has been sort of
you know
can we just kind of fold back in quietly
can we quietly go back in bro the game
aids kyle's legal defense against the
fake news interesting i didn't know that
so if you download the games it's 9.99
if you download the kyle rittenhouse's
turkey shoot yeah on rittenhousegame.com
let's not do ads for it
the game is please we'll aid kyle's
legal defense against fake news it helps
raise funds to sue the left-wing media
can he sue them how much money does it
cost to sue just sue them you tell me a
lawyer won't take that case pro bono oh
you're probably right what are we
talking about right slush fund right
some type of slush fund i mean a
lawyer's not going to take that case pro
bono what are you talking about yeah
you're right come on stop
let's not be
the kyle rittenhouse fake news turkey
shoot
video game
happy fourth of july what'd you get the
kids i got him the new kyle rittenhouse
turkey shoot game
come on in kids shoot the fake news
turkeys
thank you dad
don't shoot your classmates
shoot people you disagree with
politically
um
is there anything positive
is there ant because it's the fourth of
july
we're trying to figure out
fun upbeat stories that we as americans
can all come together and go jesus
christ do we feel good people are really
happy about this what are they happening
there's now casting open for a real-life
squid games yes well this is what we
mean the squid games which was a a a
netflix series about a dystopian society
where people without money who were in
debt
would uh be in this game
where they would be killed or win a lot
of money
now in america we're actually gonna do
it
but instead of killing the people we
will release them back into poverty tell
us more about this it's such a good idea
so netflix i like the idea of this
because it says hey it's not that cruel
we're not killing them
but everything else about it
is the same
that's what's good about this they go
we're not killing them
but every other thing about squid get
it's literally the same
yeah they're inviting contestants to
compete for
4.5
million dollars in prizes by completing
the nightmare games featured in a
cautionary tale about wealth disparity
so uh the fans this was a hit show the
fans are excited it was big they want to
be in the show
they want to be in the squid games so
there'll be 456 players who will enter
the game in a pursuit of life-changing
reward of 4.56 million dollars according
to a press release as they compete
through a series of games inspired by
the original show plus surprising new
additions their strategies alliances and
character will be put to test while
competitors are eliminated around them
and this will also be a reality show
obviously
it's a good idea get kyle rittenhouse in
this
get kyle rittenhouse in the squid game
this is not a bad idea at all
my mind is starting to
turn here
i'm starting to
understand the direction we must go
i mean when you're burned out and you're
working too much and you're not taking
enough time for yourself have you ever
felt burnt out what did it feel like to
you ben
never feel like you work too hard
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
irritability fatigue and more
we associate burnout with work but it's
not the only cause any of the roles you
play in life can lead us to feel burned
out better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life i
love better help
what's so good about it well
it's customized online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours it's great to use i'm on the go
all the time i call someone up hey
here's what's going on
it's great our listeners are getting 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
timd that's betterhelp.comslashtimd
betterhelp.com tim
d
our listeners get ten percent off their
first month at betterhelp.com
md that's betterhelp.comd
take your summer adventure to the next
level with bespoke post in the new
seasonal lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections this is great
because there's all this cool stuff in a
box and you get it once a month if you
want if not you can stop or start at any
time it's a great gift to give people
it's literally the gift it keeps on
giving to get started take a quiz at box
of awesome.com your answers will help
them pick the right box for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
each box is valued at around 70
but you only pay a fraction of that
price plus with box of awesome you're
supporting small business ninety percent
of everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small
up and coming brand
get twenty percent off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome dot com and enter the code tim
dillon at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code tim dillon for 20 off
your first box i mean how cool are these
things so my favorite boxes especially
with the summer coming up are the ones
with again they sent me another fishing
knife which is great oh
absolutely wow
will you do a little fishing over the
summer you have a fishing night i know
yeah and if you go camping you can do
the one with the pancakes you can sizzle
uh like uh like the hobbits did and the
lord of the rings you know they cook
over a campfire the eggs and the
potatoes and pancakes and stuff
is your is there nothing else is that it
uh well that's all we have of the news
it's good no no i mean i mean the
supreme court expands gun rights well
what about this roe v wade now
oh uh roe v wade roe v
wade have you heard of this
apparently there are women killing their
babies
now i'm kidding of course i am
pro-choice kill them all kill the moms
great line in the bird cage when nathan
lane goes
i say kill the mother and i know what
you're saying well the baby will die
also but it's going to die anyway let it
go down with the ship
um
roe v wait now here's the deal
they're pre-recorded we're pre-recording
this episode so i want everybody to know
that this roe v wade thing is is coming
out in a few days so i'm going to do two
reactions to this just pick the one that
happened
okay
oh my god they overturned roe v wade
that's [ __ ] up
women and poor people and
[ __ ]
roe v wade was not overturned
interesting many thought it would have
been
[Laughter]
those are the two reactions depending on
which way this news goes
fill in which i'm unaffected by roe v
wade i think
within a certain window you can have the
abortion but afterwards it gets a little
creepy when it starts to look like a
little puppy in there i don't want you
to just fillet it and take its head off
now again i'm unaffected by it because i
find women to be repulsive but
that not all of them i'm kidding many of
them that pay me i think are great and
there's a few of them that i enjoy
condoleezza rice she's a real uh fun one
now
this roe v wade thing that either was
overturned or it wasn't
what is this
we're trying to have a nice time it's
the fourth of july
whitney cummings is staying at my house
i told her it smells like paint she said
she prefers it
now
what so now can you get any information
yeah so i mean it's it's up in the air
right now but it would be a judicial
earthquake but it's been it's been
decided already
you got to remember that's been decided
so my i'm asking you what is your
opinion on the decision
my opinion on the decision is i think
it's messed up that it got overturned
and that it's going to go to the states
you think it is going to be overturned
yeah and i think you know you're going
to choose i'm gonna do one for both
where you don't know which it is ready
okay
this is an inherently complex issue and
there are very
uh heartfelt
strongly held opinions on either side
that's true thank you
now that will work no matter what
happens yeah yeah because i don't know
what's going to happen it's going to
happen soon they say
by the time this comes out roe v wade
will either be the law of the land or it
will be overturned what an odd week to
pre-record
now
what makes this interesting is i don't
care
now i do care
a little because i think women should be
able to get abortions like in the
beginning
ish
like in the beginning up until a certain
point
then it gets a little uncomfortable but
late term if like
if if it's gonna be a baby that's born
without like
like if it's going to be like a baby
that's born like
where it doesn't have like all the
hearts on the outside of the body or it
can't live
you know or it's like a gypsy there is i
understand that's a joke
don't curse me curse him no no
now
i'm saying that uh
i'm just saying that there's
late in life
there are
i mean late in the pregnancy
there are things that happen
and sometimes the the
the baby needs to get harpooned
and
i i'm not involved with it
now
my position on this has always been this
hey
is there any more dip
i
my position on this has always been
because people get very
they go nuts with this they start
screaming yelling and i always go like
this i go what do you buy this for
you know my position on roe v wade has
always been
is this a legal two family
you could do a rental if you wanted in
the back
my position on roe v wade has always
been the parking's not as bad as i
thought
i thought that the parking would be bad
it's not that bad
my position on roe v wade has been very
much like well when you do the kitchen
you do the whole thing you know just go
in there and do it
porcelain tile is fine it's durable and
it looks like marble
these are the opinions
that i've had over the years with regard
to roe v wayne
um and of course i'm for women getting
abortions and i think the government
should fund it up until the point where
it makes me personally uncomfortable
you know because it there is a certain
now what's weird about this is i guess
it's already been decided by the time
this comes out but i'm preparing
everyone for all of the there's all of
the things here you have all of my
reactions
to this [ __ ]
whoa
now
i don't know what to tell you but let's
move on here from that because that's
the our roe v wait section and it's very
important
now
it is because people you know it's i
don't know but you gotta
you gotta
it's one of those where it's like hey
you know
it's one of those where you go god damn
it
ask me about roe v wade right now
uh like in the future like where i'll be
my father i look like my father right
now ask me about roe v wade see they
might overturn roe v wade i mean every
day
my boomer father's response ask me about
roey wood my boomer fathers respond yeah
they
did you see the roe v wade news
yeah they would overturn it you know so
i was just saying that you know
i was just saying that someone was
someone was saying that and i was saying
that you know
it's just one of those things
i don't i don't know if my dad knows
what roe v wade is he probably does
i don't know if he knows what roe v wade
is
you know but is there anything else as a
as a society we can grasp onto and enjoy
and just take pride in uh rachel dolezal
has an only fans now [ __ ] yeah pop that
puss
uh she's not an unattractive woman no
not at all no no she's quite bad and
there's a market for
a white woman who pretends to be black
on only fans right oh for sure for sure
god lover
i love her and then the other thing
people some people are excited about
some people are not is that uh
that we have more gun rights now in the
country well now how did this happen
because
i thought that's what i thought this is
sneaky i thought they were gonna take
away some of them after that shooting of
all the babies in their heads but now
what happened they've gone the other way
these sneaky devils now they've gone the
other way on this huh because a bunch of
kids got uh murdered and so what did
they say they went the other way
yeah basically uh
i don't understand things with guns but
basically like you don't really need a
that concealed license now concealed
carry yeah you just have to do the test
and you have to uh you know you have to
do a test and do the thing and then but
is this isn't there a gun control bill
that was passed as well
oh was there i didn't yeah
um we're recording this in september of
2019.
uh bobby i have a video of a guy who
owns
i figure you might as well go right to
the horse's mouth there's a guy who owns
a gun store i haven't get that guy owns
that get that gun store up
let him have his say
ktla does good work shut up
where is this article been uh i do good
work uh it's uh scotus expands gun
rights in six three rulings
aborted mother's gun so they could kill
their babies
[ __ ] yeah
this is good [ __ ]
you should have to shoot your baby in
the stomach no more making it easy
right isn't this what we're doing
we recorded this in 2017.
skip to like a minute 15 in bobby get in
get in there and put the gun in the
baby's hand
um i i mean i'm you know let's watch
this oh i'll try to put the headphones
on one of these
are expected to be challenged
how could this ruling impact states like
california it's going to impact the
state very very significantly what it's
going to do is now open that door up for
those who would normally not be able to
get a ccw and not be able to get one
in the ccw secure concealed weapons
permit because they don't have to have a
good call statement now now anybody that
can pass a background check and can take
the class and pass the class you will be
able to get one
okay
so that's it so you could it's it's more
people can get guns now basically i did
confirm that
well good
so they kind of went the other way on it
but well
who knows you know
our friend steve will do it is one of
the kneel boys steve is a real good guy
in in the world and especially in the
world of the internet there are not too
many good people
left anymore truly and steve actually
helps people
and what i've seen steve do personally
is he gives people cars and houses
um
you know
i've seen him go to a hospital
and like
help a kid with cancer i don't know how
but like steve will like
dude get get get that up can we show
that oh yeah bobby can you type in steve
we'll do it actually
you know i know i joke around about him
uh you know whatever but he's actually a
good pr and i keep trying i'm gonna do
their podcast i'm sick right now i don't
want to do it when i'm sick i don't want
to get on a plane
um but i'm a very big fan of this whole
group of people and i know they've been
maligned by some people that are ultra
sensitive the nelk people but they are a
good group of people actually and they
they you know they do good things steve
has actually done a good thing i you
know i do good things all the time too
which is i'm it's never reported and no
one cares everybody talks about
everything else but what they don't talk
about the good things that i do
constantly all the time starting with
the [ __ ] charity case i have to my
left
okay
okay that i literally rescued from a
from a litter
but i i mean this steve will do it now
what all this do we have him helping a
kid with cancer yeah yeah i have a video
here it's 26 minutes well let's just
play a minute of it thank you bobby just
jump into it yeah just hop jump into it
it's for today this is steve will do
it's youtube this is steve will do its
youtube channel and he's he's helping
someone with can i mean the guy's a good
person yeah he is what is he doing here
with the
[Applause]
cancer neighbors don't mind us
yeah
so he's out here
and he's this is a girl
on crutches
oh and she has cancer and he's going to
help her yeah
all right get it off but you get my
point
it's great that he's do like he's a good
person go to his youtube channel check
out what he's doing
i don't can i just show up and start
helping people too with cancer how do
you think that'll go
no you know what i mean like why do i
feel like i'll be attacked
i'll be attacked if i try to do that if
i try to help someone with cancer i'll
be attacked
right probably sorry they'll attack me
is there like a hot 19 year old guy with
cancer who i could suck off while he
dies
check out steve will do its
youtube channel
steve will do what is the channel please
it's the steve will do it youtube
channel yes steve will do it too where
he uh gambles online and that's fun it's
really fun and he gambles sometimes with
the cancer patients he gets them all and
they all take a trip to uh the cayman
islands and gamble
steve will do it go get him thank you
i'm i'm gonna withhold judgment it's the
fourth of july
it's time to part it's time to have a
rainbow italian ice
and just sit by the window
you know it's time to go out and enjoy
yourself enough with the controversial
topics
we got to be able to find something as a
nation as a culture
we can agree on something that we like
you know insurance fraud or something
that doesn't hurt anybody
but helps
you know
something that
uh we can all coalesce around like a
um
that we feel
exemplifies what it means to be an
american
you know what does it mean to be an
american like to you i'm not putting
this to you now and then i'll answer it
what does it mean to be an american to
you
you want me to answer this earnestly i
want you to answer it earnestly and then
i'm going to answer it
earnestly as well to me an american is
above all else individuality
and um uh
owning uh your own property
uh and then the separation of uh any
sort of religious property i don't i
don't have any assets actually i lease
my car i rent my house
okay which is interesting this
definition of american doesn't include
yourself
but continue i'm still young but uh
so uh you know without uh
any sort of persuasion from outside
influence like a religion or uh
government or anything like that i can i
can be a sovereign man basically that's
what being an american is to me what is
being an american to you
this is what being an american means to
me when i was a young
boy
i went
to my friend's
sister's house who was mentally [ __ ]
she was not diagnosed mentally [ __ ]
but she was incredibly dumb
we
she went out
she left us there
we said
she said to us do not leave
you can order dominoes and watch films
we said wouldn't it be funny if we left
a fake ransom note
for her she won't believe it she's not
that stupid
so we went to the park to smoke a pack
of cigarettes we had stolen from his
mother
and we left a ransom note that said i
kidnapped the two kids if you want them
back show up to this intersection with
money
well this [ __ ]
called the police because she actually
believed that we had been kidnapped and
she started hysterically crying and she
called the police
and we didn't know what to do
and we eventually walked back to the
house while the police were outside and
she was crying and she grabbed us and
hugged us
like she still thought
that we had been kidnapped
and she had called my friend's mother
and my friend's mother knew what was
going on and she was very angry
and she pulled out outside the house
and she looked at me and my friend and
she goes i can't believe you would do
this
to your sister and then she turned
around and she looked at the girl and
she went you are a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's
what being an american means
to me
you see
everybody
has a different version
of the the joys
and the promises and the challenges of
this land
but that story
really encapsulates it
to me
i don't give a [ __ ] about this owning
property and any of that other [ __ ]
but when she looked at her and said you
are a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how stupid are you
i mean it just made me happy and it was
the summer it was a nice
it was a nice summer memory but to me
america is about having an abortion with
a gun
it's about
eating a sandwich
that's made of a sandwich
it's about being on a boat getting
[ __ ] by a boat on a boat
it's about
hitting a dog
and unlike you not adopting it
driving on
that's what america is about to me
you know
it's about drinking gasoline
enlighten your inner fire
it's about crushing pills
on a cd case
and snorting them to feel good
it's about finding friends that you only
are friends with because they have drugs
it's about getting a job you hate in the
hopes that one day you can get a job you
hate that pays more money than this one
it's about finding someone to [ __ ] who
hates you
being an american to me is about
traveling without truly ever leaving
never really appreciating anything
being handed stuff
getting a lot of things you don't
deserve and nothing you do
being handed things squandering
opportunities always attacking others
blaming
never being introspective and looking
down deep
in yourself as to why
you are where you are or how you could
have handled things better
being an american to me means being
entertaining at all times even when
killing someone
it means
that everything in life should be a
spectacle kind of an o.j simpson trial
everything
from your divorce to an argument at
breakfast everything should at all times
be insane
nothing should truly make sense outside
of the idea that it's all entertaining
and for sport
being an american to me means being
inconsiderate in a very considerate way
meaning
offending people
only once you've gotten to know them
pretty damn well
knowing the buttons to push and pushing
them
being an american to me means
figuring out that everything's full of
[ __ ] when you're about nine
and oscillating between drug food sex
addiction and the mismanagement of your
money to handle it
knowing at any time that your government
has orchestrated many different attempts
to kill and enslave you
and still enjoying top gun
it's a good film
being an american to me means never
feeling sorry for a feral cat
knowing that it'll figure it out just
like you will
being an american to me means looking at
a disabled person and knowing somewhere
down deep they deserve it
be amer being an american to me
means you can summon up a murderous rage
at the slightest inconvenience
if someone refuses to seat you
in an appropriate period of time at a
restaurant
praying that they get into a car
accident where they bash their head off
their glove compartment and they live to
deal with the debt
being an american doesn't mean wishing
death on someone it means wishing
bankruptcy multiple times that they have
to go in and out of court it doesn't
mean wishing they lose their children it
means wishing they have to raise them
being being an american to me
means everything
and also nothing at all
we're a country of 350 million people
being an american means watching people
from all walks of life all corners of
the world come here and learn
to be a psychopath
being an american to me means being
jealous vindictive petty hostile vicious
cowardly brave
also
being a liar
being a cynic
but being ultimately
hopeful
that one day the people you agree with
kill everyone else
being an american to me means concerning
yourself
with tunnels of children under the
ground
or government controlling the weather
but never
with your actual
position in life
and who's [ __ ] you that can actually
reach out and touch you
because they're out there
being an american to me
means understanding that tgif was a good
group of shows on abc and yes the kids
got raped
being an american to me means
understanding that wendy's in the 1990s
was maybe the greatest restaurant
that god
has ever given man
that the monterey ranch
chicken sandwich
with bacon
in the ranch dressing
lettuce tomato
and a slice of monterey jack-ish like
cheese
on a soft bun
while eaten
in a mazda navajo you had financed
on the way to a house you couldn't
afford
but you had somehow figured out how to
pay for that month
was a great joy
america is a collection of minutes
it's a collection of cigarette breaks
it's a collection of finding a bathroom
in a mall
it's a collection of [ __ ]
it's a collection of lost friendships
unrequited loves
opportunities you didn't take failures
small successes broken families
bitter horrible
nasty hopeless people that all come
together
every fourth of july to eat
that's what america is there's something
beautiful about it
america's industrial parks
our most beautiful places in america our
national parks have become
playgrounds for killers
to murder people who go seek out their
majestic beauty
america means that the government may
kidnap your children and try to turn
them into sex slaves or assassins
mind control victims and brainwash them
but at the end of the day entemens is a
good cake
and everyone likes it
i do
america to me is about telling your
children to go to college
so that they can go
and haze other kids and kill them
that's what america means to me
america to me means you can start a
podcast with your friends
and end up on an fbi watch list
america to me means you can move to the
greatest city in america
austin texas
and live there
in 100 degrees swampy
for a year
because it's
a truly moving experience
america means
the great comedy clubs the comedy store
the comedies
the stand and others
will be full of young children
and by young children i mean 41 year
olds
trying to make it as a buffoon
that's beautiful
america to me means that our one of our
most american sports golf
will like everything else eventually be
owned by the saudis
that's what america means to me it's a
great
country it's a beautiful place
i'm happy to be here but i would go
anywhere else
you understand
that's what america means to me i've
been incredibly blessed to live here
i've met some of the most interesting
people
in my business and other businesses
and i've realized that they're not
that interesting
and that's a blessing
that's a blessing
i've been i've met some of the
wealthiest people in the world some of
the most powerful people in the world
and i'll tell you right now there's
nothing more fun than doing cocaine with
your friend in the back of a rental car
that's america to me
america to me
comes down to three words
shut your mouth
[Laughter]
shut your mouth because someone else is
talking
and that person is smarter than you or
at least they've robbed more people
america to me is about endless
options
for pancakes
so many different types of fluffy
pancakes that you can put your head on
and sleep
america to me is about the chalky taste
that a pharmaceutical leaves as it
slides down your throat
headed to your bloodstream to make it
all better
america means finding your child oh deed
in the bathroom
[Laughter]
getting the narcan out
and reviving them
so they live to rob you one more time
that's what america means
never give up
never surrender
we have a beautiful
and very very disgusting country
and i'm proud to live here
i'm proud of all of our problems
our school shootings are tent cities
they
are our greatest strengths
it's all a matter of perspective
that's what america means to me
america means to me
sitting at a bar
next to someone
and i've done this
where you're doing shots
and their child
their 11 year old child walks in
crying
and says daddy please come home
and he goes you're not old enough to be
in here
you have to leave
okay little angel
daddy will be home soon
and then the mother comes in
and she goes how can you sit there as a
man
while your daughter cries
and asks for you to come home
and he says [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my
face
and she leaves
and then he looks at me and he goes
she's very selfish
and i said i think she is
and he goes would you like to split an
order of clams
that's what america means to me
what a selfish [ __ ]
[Laughter]
whatever america means to you out there
i don't care
doesn't mean anything to me
all i ask is that you keep listening to
our show
and keep paying us
whatever else you do
whatever genocides you commit
just know
that all we care about
is that you support us
you can beat your wife
you can torture your children
you could be like jenny's dad in forrest
gump just rape them all
but if you buy our products
if you buy tickets to see me
and you support our patreon
like they say in the opening scene of
the wire it's america man
it's america
so
with all of that
our show is exclusively moving
to saudi spotify
it will be available
only in the country of saudi arabia
and they're giving us a hundred
million
dollars
the most american thing i could think of
to do
would be to sell this podcast
to saudi arabia
the most american thing i could do
would be to open this podcast next week
sitting in full saudi garb
from a palace in riyadh
and don't think i won't do it
don't think for a minute
that i won't do it oh christ i'll do it
that is the most american thing
that i can do
it's the most american thing i can do
it's really the most american thing i
can do
because it's um
it's a country about the future
it's not about the past
it's not about oh the government did 9
11. it's what are they going to do next
it's about the future you can't
lose yourself
you have to
always focus on the great things
that are coming our way
my father said something to me
that was very brilliant
and it meant a lot to me
we were driving once
and he said to me he said son
never overestimate your worth
he said you're not that special
and anything you can do someone else can
probably do
and i always remembered that
i always remember that
i think it made a lot of sense
he said to me one day me and your mother
it's not that we don't love each other
it's that we don't love each other
anymore
we're
we're ending this marriage
you know
listen i don't it's no secret that i
don't speak to a lot of my family and
that's okay that doesn't mean much
doesn't mean anything
you know
but that's what america is
america is about family
america is about family
that's what america is about it's a big
we're a big wacky family
we're a big wacky family
and my mother
has always been
you know pretty honest with me
about this country
she's she's always been honest she said
to me you're too fat to be on television
consistently
she said if you dye your hair someone
may give you enough money to fix your
teeth
and she said barack obama's a muslim
now
my mother's a great american story
because she started out
as a wiki watchy mermaid in florida she
spent years as a surfer
then having me and then was a swim
teacher
and now
she ends uh as a paranoid schizophrenic
locked away in a room
but if we only knew about live streaming
ma
oh god
the money you could have made
the money ma could have made
if we just knew about live streaming
because man
mommy would have [ __ ] lit up those
super chats
mommy would have live streamed her way
right out
it's a question of timing
question and timing
it's unfortunate do you have anything to
add before we get out of here no that
was beautiful yes absolutely beautiful
it's almost like i'm the one that should
talk
this guy took him to homeownership he
doesn't own anything
he owns a sick dog kill it
everyone i hope you enjoy
uh your fourth of july
i hope you remember
what made this country great fraud
murder
and cool [ __ ]
cool [ __ ]
we've got cool [ __ ] here
got cool [ __ ]
people come here they go that's pretty
cool
be cool
smoke drink use drugs
make a lot of money
die very young
[Laughter]
kill others
[Laughter]
happy farts